in 2019 norwegian director
anders harmer traveled to hong kong to
document the demonstrations that erupted
after a bill was introduced allowing
criminal suspects to be extradited to
mainland china
it was the beginning of the end for hong
kong's political independence
hummer's documentary short do not split
takes viewers into the streets as
protesters go head to head with the
police in a desperate fight to preserve
their freedoms
[Applause]
do not split which premiered at sundance
has garnered glowing reviews
and an academy award nomination the film
is also one reason that the oscars won't
be broadcast in hong kong
for the first time in more than half a
century the communist party's propaganda
department issued the order to all media
outlets not to broadcast the oscars
according to anonymous sources cited by
bloomberg
along with do not split censors object
to the nomination of beijing-born
director chloe zao
who was up for best director for her
film nomad land
and was once hailed as the pride of
china but that was before a 2013
interview resurfaced
where zao recalled the china of her
youth as a place where there are lies
everywhere beijing is known to react
they will actions
in many different ways if they feel that
something is going against their their
plan
after the movie got shortlisted the
horses
many people told us that beijing would
react in one way or the other
according to variety chinese censors
have also scrubbed mention of do not
split
nomad land and the academy awards from
social media
one of the biggest social media
platforms
in china has removed oscars
2021 and that they have
had this cleaning process on the platf
platform and also removed any reference
specifically to
our documentary that has supposedly also
happened in
on other platforms in mainland china the
academy hasn't offered to alter its
program to appease beijing
but american companies including
hollywood studios do have a history of
making creative decisions
that allow them to retain access to the
chinese market
hammer expects this moral quandary to
become a bigger problem
as china's market power continues to
grow this will be
a dilemma both political organizations
and commercial organizations and
also entertainment business have to deal
with because if they
want to stand up for human rights and
they want to
take a stand against parts of beijing's
politics
that will most likely be sanctioned
ironically beijing's actions are having
the opposite of their intended effect
so we have had so many more media
requests after
this became a new story the movie had
already been
out for for a little while and this
completely
changed the situation in terms of
bringing attention to this documentary
it has become been reported in
entertainment news which is normally not
dealing too
much with political stuff uh and in that
sense i'm happy
and that says i also think that beijing
is helping the aim of this movie which
is to bring attention to the critical
situation in hong kong
also we used to have a lot of freedom
you know when i was young i never
i never thought of you know i could not
say something but now i find it
it's really maybe for something i cannot
really say for example
you know [ __ ] china maybe i can see it
today
but i'm afraid i cannot see it tomorrow
i hope
people will get emotional when they see
them
that's the aim of the documentary to
make
people care about what is going on in
hong kong
and how they are trying to
stand up against a very powerful
political leadership since hammer
returned to norway
activists and legislators who oppose
chinese rule have been arrested in mass
the city is firmly under the control of
beijing and the fight to preserve hong
kong's one country two systems rule
is effectively over whether do not split
wins on oscar night
hammer hopes his film and the increased
attention brought about by china's
censorious reaction
will shed light on what is happening in
the region these are very dark times for
hong kong i think the
development that we were following in
our documentary has just been continuing
and i don't know where it will stop and
how serious
and critical it will become i would say
it's really serious at this time and it
seems like it will continue
[Music]